[Applaudissements]
alors on a parlé de qui de nicole
scherzinger des pussycat dolls
voilà vous vouliez que l'appel oui oui
vous ne croyez pas il fallait pas que
j'ai un numéro à la votre sentiment
jeune numéro de dépouiller de 10
salariés voulaient que je peux nicholson
si elle n'est pas payée entre la photo
au 12 août tu payes pas de la photo il
répond j'aime et je pose une testicules
sur la tête
m
[Applaudissements]
notre portable
regardez je n'ai pas le forfait pour
appeler les creuser regardez je vais
appeler regarder la barque je suis quand
même nom mais regarde et attend d'être à
l'écouté de ça sinon on n'est qu'un
téléphone pendant les douze donnes pas
d'attaqué grande lucarne c'est la mer
s'il est bon ou pas mais mur d'imagés
patron de rien du tout patron d'un
tombeau appel mairie mathieu plutôt à
l'aise
y'a pas de nicole scherzinger le
problème c'est qu'à part un numéro qui
est à moi la page est pour l'a buzzé à
vous dégoûter de leur forfait le de
france est le moyen d'obtenir alors
j'appelle nicole scherzinger pussycat
dolls connaît pas
quand je te tue franck ullmann miel
réponses et les boutiques aux chocs à
stoke city mais ça sonne pas on va
retomber à la beach où j'habite il a
tenu bon les jours sur fond de moi je
sais pas où elle habite pour m'a donné
son numéro de tommy on verra ça je vais
l'appeler voulez que vos livres
pardonnez moi et mon bébé numéro dans ce
numéro il faut que ça s'est passé
c'est possible alors si vous voulez pas
d'accord ben arous de numéros ont été
battus et battu les chercher numéro tu
me fais passer